today on stick to football we have a
great show planned for you we're gonna
go around the league and then we are
debuting a new little series called
mocking the mock mellow came up with
that name it's a good one where every
day this week one host will give you
their round one mock draft the other two
hosts are gonna grade it so it's gonna
be a good time Matt Melo and Connor you
can check us out on the bleacher report
youtube channel we have a stick to
football playlist and you can catch us
wherever you get your podcast guys we
are sitting here about two and a half
weeks away from the 2020 NFL Draft and I
can tell you from my side of things I
have never felt more unprepared for a
draft because we have no idea what its
gonna look like Thursday night when
Commissioner Goodell slides into his
couch in his living room or hop sunset
at ESPN there are a lot of unknowns that
we are trying to prepare for one thing I
feel good about have had a lot of time
to study these players so I feel like I
know this class it's gonna be very weird
with the draft this year and I had
somebody ask me that this weekend and it
floored me it was the first time I'd
heard is like where's Goodell gonna be
oh you know I don't know I don't know if
he's gonna try to be in a studio
somewhere or if he's just gonna be
rockin it at home with everybody else
with their cool backgrounds I was gonna
say it's the first time that we we don't
know what to expect when we turn on the
TV there's no you know live broadcast
essentially where they're sitting there
on a set in front of a ton of people in
front of a stage this and that I'll say
this though guys as somebody and you
guys know this just as well that doesn't
get to watch the draft ever anymore you
know it's you're kind of just like
alright well we got to keep marching on
with our show so and that'll feel
different too not for the audience I
would say I feel like the audience won't
notice too much of a difference but all
of us won't be sitting next to each
other in person this year for the draft
it's gonna be different we are gonna be
covering the draft as soon as our fan
our plans get finalized we're gonna let
you guys know but we can confidently
tell you that the draft show that you've
come to love from bleacher report will
be there you'll be able to get the
analysis from the picks from us but guys
I wanted to give some news and notes I
like I mentioned last week last Friday
my scouting notebook came out it was
loaded with rumors so much so that I
couldn't get all of them in there so
held a couple back and thought I would
drop them to you guys this morning and
get
take on these I'm hearing one thing and
this is all LSU related I didn't plan
that and I didn't realize it until right
now actually it's all LSU related so go
Tigers Clyde Edwards alaire is getting a
lot of late first round interest and I
know that's something that I've talked
about before on the show that people at
LSU even thought hey you're low on this
guy he's gonna go much higher based on
our conversations with NFL teams now
having those conversations with NFL
teams sounds like our guy Clyde the
glide could be a late first rounder
mellow maybe your Kansas City cheese I
think he's a perfect fit in that offense
but I know not all Chiefs fans are on
board with him taking and running back
at 32 and I don't I don't know if Andy
Reid's gonna pull the trigger on the
first round on a guy that ran for six I
know that speed is not very important at
running back but I think it is for the
Kansas City Chiefs I don't know if I'm
buying the interest in the first round
that's I think he's running back for for
me and honestly cam akers might catch
him I'm just not getting the vibe of a
first round running back out of him he's
another guy that at a position where you
can be very productive and it's easy to
see okay this guy's good he's had one
productive season so I'm not buying the
first round love on client Edwardson
later I might be the odd guy out here
but I really just don't don't like LSU
players on offense they know I like all
of them
I actually I really like Justin
Jefferson I think he's gonna be very
good I think he's the best player coming
out of LSU when you look at position
wise I would take him over guys like
Edward Slayer or even you know I think
he'll have a better career than Joe
Burrell just go ahead and say it but you
know running back position you can be
very productive on bad teams cam Akers
did it and we only saw one year out of
out of Clyde to Edwards hair Hilaire so
it makes me very leery of taking these
LSU guys I'm not buying it either I look
at this number one I don't think a
running back is going in the first round
of this draft and if any of them do it
should be one of DeAndre Swift or
Jonathan Taylor I think the problem with
Clyde who I really like as well but like
you mellow I see him as the fourth best
running back in this class I don't think
he's ready for you know to be a past
protector at the NFL level yeah I think
that's a part of his game he really
needs to round out and that means he's
probably not gonna get on the field the
way a first-round running back too often
does I think he gets on the field a lot
I don't think he gets this a qualm
barclays kind of workload so I think
when you look at this it would be really
tough for me to use a first round pick
on a running back in this class but if
it was gonna be one of them it would be
Jonathan Taylor or DeAndre swift but
Clyde will probably go in the top fifty
as we've been saying for a very long
time I still worry about Jonathan
Taylor's fumbles I love everything else
about this guy like even the 900 carries
a little concerning not a huge deal but
like the fumbles I just can't get I
don't how are you guys when you look at
him and you see okay eighteen fumbles in
college is it that a lot of them
happened when he was trying to move the
pile at the end of a run I just I know
you've said Adrian Peterson before Melo
I just see a guy and I'm like how do we
feed you the ball at the level you need
it when we can't trust you to hold on to
it oh I think ball security is one of
the easiest things to teach her running
back how to do I hope one of the hardest
things to teach her running back how to
do run fast Jonathan Taylor can do that
he can run with power he can run with
speed he's elusive the one problem that
he really has is I fumbles too much
we've seen guys do that we've seen them
fix it it's not like man this guy has
poor decision-making at quarterback we
can't really fix that you can fix ball
security it's very easy to do I think by
year two in the NFL he's gonna have it
figured out because they won't put up
with it in the NFL when you get to
Wisconsin you're a standout freshman
you're blazing fast on the track they
might put up with a couple fumbles and
the NFL they're going to fix it they're
going to have you working on it every
day at Wisconsin I don't think his job
was ever on the line of who you put that
ball on the ground again you're out of
here so that's what it separates a guy
like Jonathan Taylor and Clyde Edwards
layer you look at him he's 5-7 207 is he
gonna be able to take the pounding of
the NFL I know that Jonathan Taylor at
225 can and he did it in the big 10
taking so many carries so that doesn't
scare me at all I mean Taylor is bigger
faster stronger it checks every single
box in that regard and to answer your
question Matt I guess that's the only
concern I really have but it's not one
where it stopped me from putting him as
the second best running back in this
class and I love JT I don't even think
the gap between him and Swift is very
very big I actually think there's a gap
between Swift and JT
- Dobbins Clyde were to layer and cam
akers and I know a lot of people have
had Dobbins grouped in with those top
two running backs I don't see it like
that at all I think if you want one of
the stars of this class it's really
starts and ends with Swift and Taylor
and I don't I don't think it starts in
the first round though it's not so for a
guy like Clyde of Bruce Lee like even if
he is the number three number two back
on people's boards and it could be I
still don't know if you're pulling that
trigger in the first round there's just
so many good running backs that I would
rather wait and take one of them like if
I can't get Jonathan Taylor in the first
round I'm okay with JK Dobbins in a
second I have Edward Solaris my running
back - and I think you know like grade
wise he's gonna be in the late 20s but I
do think like you said I would just
because he's a running back I would
rather have that player early around to
another LSU player who's regaining steam
as it was put to me as Christian Fulton
who you know battled through a little
bit of an injury this year with an ankle
but played through it and that's
something I'm hearing that teams are in
love with the fact that he played
through this injury now I have Fulton as
an early round two player I think he is
a good scheme fit for some teams and not
so much others tested better than I
expected but again we got the ankle out
there and you know an early career
suspension I believe for a I'm not
actually gonna I'm not I don't misspeak
but an early career suspension so just
google it yeah yeah Christian Fulton
really interesting player technically
sound very very strong can play press
coverage and we've seen him matched up
against some of the best of the best
over the last four years for the Tigers
defense I don't personally have him as
the number three corner in this class
but hearing a lot of teams do and this
is a guy you talked about my Kansas City
Chiefs drafting at 32 I'd be happy with
this with Fulton going 32 overall I was
trying to pull up my big board and see
where he's at I know he's not in front
of a CUDA I know he's not in front of
Henderson I think you get to like
cornerback for I have Jeff gladden III
but then you're getting the guys like
trav on digs like I really could see him
being special being very athletic at
corner being able to run with everybody
and then you know Christian fold and AJ
Terrell we've seen them be very good at
times we also seen him look really
add on the big stage but for a guy like
Cristian Fulton maybe he was banged up
last year I mean we heard it during the
season it's not like this is coming out
during the draft process I think a lot
of people knew this is a guy that was
hurt and he's going to start rising up
draft boards I'm buying this one you're
gonna see it in the mock draft today
there are just too many teams in the
first round that need corner backs and I
think they're gonna be too afraid the
team is picking in the back end of round
one to wait till round two because they
might miss the boat so I think when you
look at it you have guys like Fulton
Melo mentioned Diggs and Terrell those
guys can eat jaylen Johnson I mean those
guys can really easily be top 35 picks
here in this class because a lot of them
are long corners with adequate speed and
when you look at Fulton for me I mean I
was high on him for a while I just I
actually even concerned about the
injuries I'm not sitting here
celebrating that he played through it I
do think he's a very very tough player I
do wonder if he's somebody that'll just
be banged up and when you look at you
know CJ Henderson just owned the combine
with how athletic he is then you go back
on film he drew some really really tough
matchups especially when you watch
against Jamar chase they kind of let him
matchup against him one-on-one and just
not a lot of people can handle Jamar
chase like that
the one-on-one in the country as a whole
and Henderson did a decent job not a
great or bad one but a decent job so for
Fulton he's been passed by a couple guys
but I'm buying that he goes in the first
round of this draft yeah I think so as
well whether it's 31 32 there's enough
teams they're late the Vikings with one
of their two picks the end of round one
could definitely see that happening
right last thing and then we'll take a
break and get into Connors mock draft
Lloyd cushion Barry fellas getting some
late first round love as well I believe
this assumes that Cesar Ruiz from
Michigan is off the board but Lloyd who
it was an anchor of that offensive line
what I'm hearing is teams are in love
with the athleticism and the football IQ
I can't find a spot for him late first
round but that's of course without
factoring in trades if race is off the
board 31 or 32 I think it's possible but
I just in mind like mock drafts that
I've done I've never been able to find a
spot for Lloyd in the first yeah me
either and I like him but it more of a
second-round guy kind of like the
running back to I don't want to just
[ __ ] on LSU because that's not a fan
base that you want to piss off
I like your team good job you won the
national championship but I don't see
him as a first-round guy maybe if we see
a team reach for Ruiz maybe then you get
a team later in the back half of the
first round that says well we still need
a sinner we really like this guy in
cushion berry let's go ahead and take
him but I still see him more as a a
second-round type guy and that's the
same for me as well when you look at it
with cushion berry the reason Matt this
report is definitely believable is
because the interior line class just
doesn't have a lot of guys at the top of
it you know you can we do it in mock
drafts every single week
yeah you take Ruiz off the board and
then you go well that's it for a while
so if there's a next guy up especially
the center position you know that a guy
that's been reliable and played on the
championship team it would be cushion
berry but I still think he doesn't hear
his name called in the first round
I wish Robert hunt were healthy from
Louisiana I love him I think he's the
second best interior guy in the class I
I agree the only thing that has him down
for me is injury and and it's serious
because of good old coronavirus guys
can't get checks we don't even know you
know is it an injury that he's gonna be
okay
if there's a season in September a lot
of unknowns when it comes to a lot of
the injured players in this year's class
all right let's take a break we cut back
Connor is on the clock with Cincinnati
Bengals and Melo and I we just get to
kick back and grade this one we'll be
back I'm sick football
we are kicking off our mocking the mocks
here April 6 Connor gets to go first he
volunteered what a gentleman Melo and I
again we just get kicked back Connors
gonna go through his picks we're gonna
hop in and grade I guess his mark draft
we're experimenting with this it's gonna
be a good time though guaranteed so
Connor are you doing a what you would do
mock or what you think is this a
prediction so I decide to do what I
think will happen it's a prediction okay
I like those better
I think there's what people want at this
stage a couple weeks before the draft I
take it away I'm sure a lot of suspense
with number one overall so since there
isn't any suspense with number one
overall I want to ask you guys I put you
a burrow here to the Bengals
would you guys entertain any offers if
you were Cincinnati I've been thinking a
lot about this because of it I mean you
actually get asked about this a decent
amount just from you know VPS and GM's
and things like that like hey what do
you think it would take and I'm always
like
gosh I feel like it's gonna take they
have 3 first this year to next year and
they have like 4 second-round picks
between those two years I believe it
would take all three first this year and
one next year to do it I just don't know
the Dolphins roster is not that good to
where you can like you still need two
tackles so I don't think you can trade
for first-round picks for a quarterback
and then like there's decided Bengals
fans get very upset if you mentioned it
like if you even throw this scenario out
there so I don't think the Bengals
wouldn't necessarily do it I was
actually talking to someone last week
very high ranking NFL person and what
they told me was the only way they could
see the Bengals doing this is if jobber
oh let it be known behind the scenes
like hey I I would prefer not to play
here so you might want to get as much as
you can for me but no one that I know
thinks that Jo burrows that kind of guy
I I don't think so if I'm the Bengals I
would listen I listen to offers you look
at I mean you have Trevor Lawrence
sitting there next year and I know it's
very hard to tank and and get your guy
the Bengals they did it this year
so if I can get four first-round picks
and somebody else comes and takes Joe
borough and I can put myself in a good
position to get a guy like Trevor
Lawrence I would I would listen to
offers I don't know if I would take any
but you bet your ass I would listen to
offers alright number two no shock here
either I did not go the quarterback
route I think Washington will take chase
young and form a really really good
front seven for Ron Rivera early on yeah
that's I mean that's the way to do it
and I I had had this in last week's
getting no but there I've been told
they're not gonna take a quarterback
it's just let's not overthink this let's
just take chase young and give her an
Rivera what he wants however the Lions
we've said for a long time this is where
the draft kind of starts what direction
do you have them going so this is where
it gets fun boys buckle up the lines
traded this pick to the Chargers okay
Chargers move up and in return so the
Chargers move up to three and the Lions
got obviously the Chargers sixth overall
pick they got their second and
third-round picks this year so 37 and 71
and their second-round pick next year
okay that's that's a lot to trick up
three spots but when you're trading up
when you train for a quarterback right
six to three in 2018 and they gave up
three twos so they actually saved on a
two here so this is two second-round
picks a third-round pick and then swap
first this year yep and you only go back
in three spots
yep and the Chargers take to it if I'm
the Lions
I like that trade I think you're sitting
there and I don't want to try to predict
your draft but if I'm looking at it from
the Lions standpoint I can probably
still get Jeff Acuto definitely still
gave Jeff a CUDA Isaiah Simmons right
they should both be sitting there I the
Dolphins are pissed though Connor I do I
think this happens whether it's the
Chargers or the Dolphins or some you
know maybe the Raiders get crazy into it
I really think that this happens on
draft day because it makes too much
sense and like Melo said so what I was
waiting to say damn it the Lions still
get their guy and they gain three picks
like you are dumb for if you're the
Alliance like you're pretty dumb if you
don't do it like we're like worst-case
scenario for them they're still sitting
there if you're Detroit and you can
still get a guy like Derek brown like
even if it goes a CUDA and the Lions are
like [ __ ] it or sorry the Dolphins they
don't know what to do they take Simmons
or vice versa you're still sitting there
and you can get a very good defensive
player at number six overall and the
Panthers are probably gonna start
panicking because now all these
defensive players are going so I do
agree with you guys - I think this is
something that we can see happen on
draft day it's not something we predict
a lot when we do our mock drafts because
it's so difficult but with Connor doing
his right here I do think the Chargers
are actively calling Detroit probably
every day trying to work something out
so you love it for the Lions now let's
talk about the Chargers that gave up two
second-round picks in a third while
swapping their first and they get to a
if he's healthy it's worth it and that's
the key you just you have to trust your
doctor if you take to a that's it I mean
the charger so I don't feel great about
it but right if he's healthy he's worth
the third pick in this draft he really
is I mean I know we had reports last
week teams are down on him I'm not he's
still my number two quarterback he's
still a top six player I believe his
vision his ability to throw with
anticipation with touch with accuracy
I really really liked to it so yeah if
he's healthy this is a really smart pick
yeah I think so too and I think with the
quarterback position with these two guys
you're kind of rolling the dice you're
taking a risk on both of them here but
if it hits you're gonna look like a
genius in 10 years
the Chargers could come back and say man
we only gave up two second-round picks
and a third to get our franchise
quarterback and like the guy that helped
us compete with Pat mahomes do you
remember what the Chiefs gave up to get
mahomes nope doesn't matter right who
cares what the Texans give up to get
deshaun Watson don't care you know one
reason is that if you get your
quarterback no one will care you could
look back and say me we gave up three
first-round picks but we got Pat mahomes
yeah okay that was or even you know a
deshaun Watson it doesn't matter if you
get your quarterback it doesn't matter
what you gave up for it all right number
four once again not really shocking here
the Giants pass on the offensive line
class and take Isaiah Simmons yeah I've
had this one for a while as well I just
I feel too good about the people telling
me it's gonna be Isaiah Simmons for it
not to be I personally think they need
an offensive tackle they need a left
tackle Nate Soldier you never known that
guys gonna be healthy left tackles much
more valuable than defender to me so if
it were what I would do it would be a
you would have like a long internal
debate sitting in your basement trying
to figure out is that isaiah simmons
like a rare generational type defender
or one of these offensive linemen who i
personally i don't have any of these
linemen ranked better than I had Jonah
Williams last year like I think it's a
good tackle class but there's not one of
them that I'm like that's Trent Williams
or that's time I really like Jedrek
wills I think he could be in play here
but I also think that they are probably
ready to address the defensive side of
the ball and you get the best defensive
weapon that I've seen while doing this
so Isaiah Simmons makes sense if you're
the Giants I mean he's very I think he's
number four overall on my board that's
where he goes in this draft so it fits
alright five Miami's on the clock they
got jumped by the Chargers for two uh
they sit tight and get their guy in
Justin Herbert I this is gonna be like
the Giants last year you know where it's
like can't like you heard it was coming
you just didn't want to believe it and
then it happens and you throw your hands
up and you're like well
well I hope it works for them I am NOT a
Justin Herbert fan I know as we get
closer to the draft you're seeing a lot
of NFL Network and ESPN guys really push
Herbert I think that's because he's
gonna go early not because they like him
yeah I agree I didn't like if you okay I
get everybody's like put the Rose Bowl
and the senior ball were so good the
senior rule seven on seven yeah so I
mean what about the other three years
that he's you know like the three years
it taped that we have of this guy
playing like a deer in headlights I know
he has a strong arm and I have him
ranked at like twenty four overall or
something because there's a little part
of me that thinks damn if this guy gets
in a one read system and he and he's
able to use his legs I could be proven
wrong about him but I'm like 90% sure
that he won't be I'm like a 97% sure he
won't ever be a top-ten quarterback in
the NFL it's I mean you don't see very
many quarterbacks in a draft class hit
usually you get about one or two and the
rest are kind of duds and get replaced
I'm not a fan of Justin Herbert either
but this reminds me a lot of the Buffalo
Bills and your guy Josh Allen we had
heard for years they're like oh they
really like Josh own they really like
him it seems like the Dolphins are doing
the same thing and I think if they
really love to if they really wanted to
uh they probably would have already
traded up for it but they haven't yet
we're still hitting here April 6th draft
is just around the corner and we still
haven't had a trade up to that number
three spot or that number two spots so
they must be thinking yeah we'll just
sit around and wait for Justin Herbert
if the Dolphins like to it they have
executed one of the best smoke screens
that I can remember yeah yeah can i
hijack this for just one say I want to
ask you guys go ahead because neither of
you neither of you really liked Josh
Allen do you have Josh Allen ranked
higher than Justin Herbert it's close
because I haven't done like grades over
the years like you have so it's easy for
you to look back and say like yeah I
would probably bet on Josh Allen's
athletic ability when I'm comparing them
I'm still not real sold on Josh Allen as
a quarterback but he has proven that he
can win games now looking back at him as
a prospect though he had an incredibly
strong arm you can't debate that
he was very athletic I think Justin
Herbert has a pretty strong arm and he's
okay athletically so I would probably
still have Joshua Allen ahead of Justin
Herbert and I didn't like Josh Allen
yeah I like Josh Allen better just
because of his mental makeup like Melo
said he a little more athletic
I think the arm was stronger I don't
know I think the mental makeup thing was
very important to me I mean I know we
got to talk to Josh a couple of times
before that draft but you talked to
everybody that was around him it's just
very very different kind of people and I
would consider myself very low on
Herbert I mean guys he's been holding on
for dear life in my top 50 right now Wow
agreed agree here buddy what like if I
don't think he's gonna be a good
quarterback why am i putting him in yeah
like 30 players and that's my thing too
like I've got some really good players
here at the end of like the 30s like
void cushion Barry who we talked about
Grant del fat jaylen Johnson Kyle Duggar
I'm just not gonna reach on a guy just
because he's a quarterback I have
Herbert at 47
I wouldn't take him in the first round I
wouldn't even entertain his name in the
first round if I'm the Chargers or the
Dolphins and those two quarterbacks are
gone I would go with another position I
would not take him in the first time my
big board ABS Melo knows because a draft
400 is in flux right now so I know what
number grade I put on Justin Herbert
where he like where he gets ranked in
that 400 right now is TBD it's looking
complete but I like that you're both
standing on the table and said now but
we don't like this guy why should we
rank him highly all right I will
unsigned sidetrack us now six the Lions
in a trade back Connor where you got him
going I mean you got no surprises here
the Lions come out as big winners early
on because they're sitting there with
two extra second-round picks an extra
third round pick and at six they get
Jeff Okuda guys I'd already put the pick
in for you in the database I knew this
is a smart pick it's a smart decision
too like we were talking about earlier
for the Lions
they have a lot of holes to fill on this
team and I think you still get your guy
who is number two on my board Jeff a
CUDA I absolutely love his game number
two on my board only chase young in
front of him I think he's one of the
best corners that's gonna be in the
National Football League in the next ten
years he's gonna be a shutdown guy
I physically asked the ball skills turn
and run like I don't know what it is
that he does wrong you have to list a
weakness for dry 400 good luck I don't
know what it is that he struggles with
all right number seven keeping it moving
here I do think this pick as a chance to
be someone like Derek Brown the more and
more you look at the roster but I just
can't justify passing on Jedrek wills
here for the Panthers guys when I look
at it their offensive line this isn't a
pick about right now although it is
because you're helping Teddy and those
weapons I mean how long is Russell oh
[ __ ] gonna be the answer here for the
Panthers so I go with exactly that's
exactly right and that might be four
weeks in August so I'm not passing on
Jedrek Wilson the spot and the Panthers
shouldn't either yeah yeah I agree with
that one too because you look at how
successful LSU was last year that the
best offensive line in the nation and I
think Joe Brady is gonna be able to
recognize that and say hey you want to
make this offense tick give me some big
boys up front give me one of these
tackles that are still on the board here
let's get the best one in this class
yeah especially with Isaiah Simmons off
the board I I've always thought the
moves that they've made have pointed to
them going another position maybe Derek
Brown will be the guy here but the
Panthers are a tough one to figure out
at this point for me right like Jedrek
quills make some more impact on your
team now and in the long term than a guy
like Derek Brown will be so that's why I
think the pick would be like guard until
Okun's hurt and week five I mean he's
already played right tackle and I think
that he could play all over that
offensive line yep
eight this is something Matt alluded to
in our rumor show last week the
Cardinals now that they have the andre
hopkins they pass on the wide receiver
classier and they take Derek Brown to
boost their defensive line
I believe it so I'm good with that my
mock drafts whenever we do these went
out whatever day I'm going will have
this pick as well yeah and I think with
the Cardinals I was kind of a believer
that old cliff was just gonna sit back
and take offense after offense but a lot
of word coming out of Arizona that
they're gonna start building this
defense
Derek browner we just talked about him
as maybe a possibility for the Panthers
he can wreck the interior of an
offensive line he can get that
penetration and he can really help
generate some pressure from the outside
- he's gonna free up guys
like a Chandler Jones so I like this
pick for the Cardinals it's not
something I thought they would do a
month ago but I think they have to start
looking at building this defense because
the offense is looking pretty damn good
number nine Jacksonville on the clock
here and they get what's regarded as the
number one wide receiver in this draft
for many that is Jerry Judy so no CJ
Henderson here no defense no offensive
line they helped Gardner Minshew and get
him a weapon in Jerry Judy at nine I
love it cuz Judy's my guy and I think
it's odd that I mean we've even had it
happened like how is he on the board of
15 I I hope that Judy's one of those
players is just being over evaluated too
much exposure to a player sometimes you
start to find weaknesses that aren't
there I think that's what's happened to
our guy yeah I think so too and you look
at Judy and easy it's I don't want to
say this name but Jerry Rice never did
anything exceptionally well like you
watch him you're like how is this the
best receiver of all time Jerry Judy
it's like you watch him and how is he
the best prospect in this class he
doesn't have the best hands he doesn't
have the best 40 it's the things that
you can't see setting up defenders with
routes in his hips
I like this pick number nine overall for
me the Jaguars I have no idea where
they're gonna go I think that receivers
an option but I also wouldn't be
surprised if they went Corner if they
reach for a guy like that but Jerry Judy
if he's on the board at nine I think
he's definitely in play with
Jacksonville alright ten the Browns
things kind of fall into their favor
here guys I can see them taking I I have
them taking Makai Becton in this spot
now I've been vocal that I like wharfs
and Thomas and Will's more than Becton I
think the NFL will like Becton more than
me and I think the Browns will not let
him get out of the top ten here they
take the mammoth tackle that let's be
real Nick Chubb can run behind right now
you're just developing his past
protection overall I can't like you
could put anyone in the world here and I
couldn't tell you that you're wrong
because we have no idea what the Browns
to do they'll probably trade back well
III think they'll take an offensive
tackle I think they'll actually take
Makai Becton who I don't really like but
I see the upside I have him number 30
overall in my big board the NFL probably
likes him a lot more than I do
you I don't see the like big-time strong
finisher than a lot of other people do
but I do think sitting here number 10
overall that the Cleveland Browns are
gonna look at him and say we can develop
him he can help us in the run game and
he can protect Baker Mayfield feels a
huge need I think they take a tackle at
10 and with Becht in there they probably
do it
alright the tackle run begins cuz the
Jets are on the clock now at 11 and
they're doing the same thing they are
probably jumping for joy as Tristan
worse false of them here at 11 guys yeah
this is very realistic and it's funny
with wharfs he could be the first tackle
off the board or he could be the third
and it would not surprise me at all it's
just a matter of your scheme and if you
project his athleticism forward I do
he's the second tackle in the class for
me and I believe that he could be an old
pro a guard or a very very good tackle
at either spot yeah I think he's the
safest pick at the offensive line
position in this draft because it a
minimum I think is even a guard in the
league for a very long time that's very
good so you get somebody to protect Sam
d'Arnaud maybe now in the second round
they can start to get him some targets
all right 12 the Raiders on the clock
here Jerry Judy is off the board but
they are still looking at this wide
receiver class they're getting some
speed here guys to pick we've talked
about for half a year
Henry rug's to the Raiders at 12 it's
perfect and I'm already smiling because
this sets up perfectly for the 49ers at
13 so I really hope this happens I know
rug's does fit well here if Derrick
cards there guy I mean one thing that's
been missing is speed some of the
stretch to feel vertically they tried to
get it with Antonio Brown now they get
it with Henry rugs yeah and I think this
pick just makes too much sense I'm
probably going to just write it and pin
for every mock draft I have to do
I think rugs is gonna be there at 12 and
I think he's gonna be the pick you need
some targets for derrick karr go get the
fastest one in the class all right since
9 it's been tall wide receivers and
tackles guys and that is not slowing
down anytime soon the 49ers at 13 get CD
lamb I hope that you cut this to my face
on YouTube because I'm I would be so
happy with this pic CD lamb and the
Niners offense is Michael Thomas like
that's that's what he's gonna do he's
gonna run a slant routes he's gonna come
back he's just gonna use that
physicality to keep defenders he's gonna
shield the ball basically from defenders
no he's not a deep threat don't care
they got that guy he and
but will dominate between the hashes I
mean it's just it's gonna be old-school
West Coast football for the 49ers yeah I
really like CD lamb as well I have him
number seven overall and I think he's
he's catching Jerry Judy I mean what
he's able to do after the catch I think
that he's gonna be best chance for a Pro
Bowl receiver year one is gonna be CD
lame especially in the 49ers offense
with guys like debo already there
they're gonna have some speed at
receiver as well it just endless targets
for Kyle Shanahan
all right 14 the Bucks like I said wide
receivers and tackles all the way down
the stretch here the Bucks got to feel
pretty good guys because they still need
some help on their offensive line for
Tom Brady they get Andrew Thomas here
the left tackle from Georgia and
three-year starter of three years five
sacks allowed in three years in the SEC
that's an amazing stat for Andrew Thomas
and Tom Brady has to be really happy
this might be the best left tackle I'm
trying to go back and think I don't want
to like 491 right I mean the heirs of
Thomas is I know we don't talk a lot
like his ceiling isn't that high that
boy's floor is real high he's ready to
come in and play very very good right
away he might not get a whole lot better
but what he is right now is a pretty
good left tackle in the NFL yeah I think
he's gonna be a good left tackle too I
wonder if they would go defense here but
I also think Tom Brady is probably in
the ear of that front office and they
know they have an old quarterback you're
going to want to protect him and help
free up Ronald Jones high offensive line
is so important in the NFL that's why we
see some guys like you know an Andrew
Thomas maybe not the best tackle in this
class but it's so damn important that
you have to get these guys and I think
Andrew Thomas fits here with what they
want to do in Tampa and I'll say it once
again Jake from is not a guy that does
you any favors when you're a past
protecting offensive linemen I mean he
kind of sits back there you know he
sometimes moves into pressure I just was
very underwhelmed by his ability in the
pocket and don't think he did Andrew
Thomas or Isiah Wilson any favors there
15 the Broncos this guy waited a little
longer than usual to hear his name come
off the board but that's why his bet on
FanDuel is to be taken before or after
15 and a half
I took the under so I had to put it here
Broncos take CJ Henderson and to add to
their corners and guys I think he is a
perfect scheme fit for Vic Fangio he is
and I feel like I always think I'm the
president of the CJ Henderson fan club
and then Melo talks on oh well maybe
maybe I'm not maybe I'm the vice
president of the CJ Anderson fan club I
love him here this sucks for Melos
chiefs and it sucks for the rest of AFC
West because CJ Henderson is a dog in
coverage and I if we get football I am
all in on he and Tyree Killa going head
to head yeah I think he fits that mold
of what they want to do I think that he
is tall he's got the speed that's what
you need a corner I think that the
tackling issues were not even true
really I really like CJ Henderson I
thought he could have been in play at
9:00 for the Jaguars at 15 though if
you're the Broncos you have to start
thinking about how do we slow down these
teams how can we get in front of the
Chiefs we probably have our quarterback
a receiver they're all gone so I don't
think that's an option I think CJ
Henderson is the perfect fit right here
for the brunt and you steal them from
the Falcons yep that's exactly right
so the Falcons here their consolation
prize right before we take a break at 16
they get chip Vaughn Kinlaw to play next
to Grady Jarrett and Dante Fowler very
very good consolation prize like this is
a top 10 player that we somehow always
have fall and these mock drafts because
the run-out tackles and wide receivers
Jesus talked about plug and play any
defense you want to run yeah that's what
I was going to say like in Los so good
and we talked about how man he could get
drafted ahead of Derek Brown but then he
falls in all of our mock drafts I do it
too but sitting here at 16 Javon Kinlaw
might be the pick even if CJ Henderson
were available this guy just like Derek
Brown can rack an offensive line but he
does it I think with more speed he might
be a better player than Derek Brown all
right guys number 17 the dowse Cowboys
are on the clock and they lost Robert
Quinn in for agency this year they still
need a little help on the edge I'm not
gonna rely on the return of Aldon Smith
just yes so we're gonna go Kayla Vaughn
chase on here at 17 to do it all
linebacker from LSU
but he is loaded up with pass rush
trades guys yeah I love him redshirt
sophomore who got to where 18 at LSU
that is a huge huge honor speaks to the
character the work ethic of this player
I know the production wasn't there I
think it's
seven sacks this year he was really just
starting to turn it on and as I've said
before I love the three-down ability
from Chase on him he's there for Dallas
this is a gigantic steal he's my number
nine overall player so I really like to
fit for Dallas and that defense and what
they want to do with a guy who is a
little bit smaller to play that edge
position I think I've mocked him to a
lot of teams that run the three-four so
he can get standing up but I like what
he can do I think that he can even play
with this you know out of a stand up
formation or put his hand in the dirt
three down player one of the best edge
rushers now there's just such a fall-off
that I think we could see chase on go
higher than 17 because after chase on
gross tomatoes maybe and then after that
I think there's a huge gap between the
next tier of edge rushers all right 18
the Miami Dolphins they got Justin
Herbert at number five overall but as
Matt alluded to in the beginning of the
show a team that really still needs
offensive line help and they're gonna
take Josh Jones the tackle from Houston
at 18 overall man yeah I feel like there
was a point in time where I was really
high on Josh Jones like and I still like
him but I mean like high relative to the
rest of the community I think 18 is a
pretty big reach for him I know they
need a tackle like they're all off the
board and I he is a developmental guy I
think Josh Jones where he could be in
three years is a pretty good left tackle
where he is right now they need tackles
so badly that you kind of have to do
this but I I just wanted to like I
wanted to say this is a reach I do think
it happens but I think it's a reach and
that's why I think with number five
overall if you don't get the quarterback
you want take one of those tackles
because you're looking at the Dolphins
right now with what they have Justin
Herbert who I and I'm not trying to [ __ ]
on Connors Mach here I think this is the
way it's gonna play out
you get Justin Herbert and Josh Jones if
I'm a Dolphins fan I'm not happy about
that you have all these picks in this
draft and you're not getting players
that are gonna be real heavy impact guys
that's why I think you have to either
trade out of these picks to trade up and
get to a or don't take a quarterback at
five don't type you know yourself to
Justin Herbert take a tackle set up
yourself for success success then there
may be a 18 take a running back or how
about this at five Tait ejected
Jedrek wilson 18 take Jordan love yeah I
think that's some upside to the Dolphins
better be on the phone this week because
I I don't like that draft pick for them
with Herbert and Jones I'm not telling
you if I'm a fan of the Dolphins I would
be pretty pissed off with that I agree I
don't like it either
I just with Herbert at five I'm not
gonna pass on it until it doesn't happen
yep right we'll have 18 it's like man
when you google or our lads who they
have a tackle it's like whoa you know
they have to do something about it so
I'm with you I would I would have taken
wills at five if this is a what I would
do Mach 19 the Raiders taking Patrick
Queen they I think still think I think
they did a lot of nice things in free
agency
Patrick Queen brings a cover element at
the linebacker position that starts to
round out their defense especially after
they got Henry rugs at 12 I I said this
on in a mock draft a couple weeks back I
had this exact thing happen and I wrote
in there that I know you had it Cory
Littleton I know you added nitkowski you
still need another linebacker and I got
the same thing because I always mocked
the Raiders taking a linebacker and
people would come at me on Twitter and
be like oh why would they take the
linebacker when you have Cory Littleton
and you've addressed these needs because
you still need another one and Cory
Littleton is a free agent for a reason
he went on I liked him but I think
Patrick Queen is probably going to steal
that job very soon be a very good line
Bakshi's Middleton at middle and Queen
at week and you know you need some guys
solved to stop the Kansas City Chiefs
and the Denver Broncos who are gonna be
very good the Chargers got their
quarterback of the future in this mock
draft I think you have to continue to
address the defense and Patrick Queen is
the best offensive player on the board
right now and he feels somewhat of a
need maybe not the biggest need that you
have but with Henry rugs Patrick Queen
you got a whole lot better and you get
the guys that they're going to target
those alpha dogs from big programs you
got two of them if you're the Raiders
yeah a couple other picks I considered
here guys Jeff Gladney Christian Fulton
jaylen Johnson the the corner group here
but I think Queen is just a better
player and I know little tin can cover
but why not have two linebackers that
can cover in today's patch happy Anna
20 Jacksonville this might be your
second shock of the giraffe tear guys I
know were all excited about Gardner
Minshew and I know he can play next year
I am taking Jordan love here to develop
in Jacksonville
just in case Gardner Minshew does not
work out Lightner do not hate this at
all I've I'd know they're all in on the
mustache mania and I liked Gardner it's
a sixth-round pick or wherever he went
the draft pretty late I don't know that
he's gonna be the guy long-term so I
almost wonder if Jacksonville's
overhyping men shoot so that they can
steal someone like Jordan love I mean he
played well at times but I think it was
more mania than it was production for
men shooing to not have any expectations
coming in to like oh this guy's actually
playing pretty well he's a sixth round
pick I don't think he's the future at
quarterback there either and with Jordan
love maybe you're getting a you know a
Pat mahomes like quarterback at 20 I'm
okay with taking the risk on a guy with
huge upside and keep in mind they got
Jerry Judy at nine yeah it's something
to work with they're 21 the Philadelphia
Eagles a pick you probably hear if you
listen to mock TRAF Monday every week
that is Justin Jefferson from LSU this
feels like one as Melo said earlier just
go ahead and put this one in ink because
and here's a I know this is Conor smock
draft but I'll tell you guys when I
write a mock draft the way I do it picks
that I've heard are gonna happen I
submit them in and the work around them
it's like Derrick brown at 8 justin
jefferson at 21 I used to do this with
the kid from Texas to New England
Malcolm Brown yeah yeah it was like Oh
heard that was happening let me go ahead
and lock that one in this just like I
will go ahead and think Justin
Jefferson's is an eagle even if someone
else drafts him because we've had this
happen so many times yeah and I like
this pick two because they definitely
have to get a receiver and I talked
about Justin Jefferson earlier I think
that he's gonna be a very good receiver
I don't think he's in that top tier
that's a pretty damn special top tier of
receiver I think in a normal draft when
you don't have those three guys Justin
Jackson is the number to number one
receiver as a prospect i I mean he
probably should be taken in the top ten
based off what he did at LSU based off
his tape there's just three guys in
front of him that are special so
him at 21 should make the Eagles very
happy 22 the Minnesota Vikings here they
trade Stefon Diggs they get an extra
first rounder in this draft they're
gonna load back up at wide receiver guys
and they don't go T Higgins here they go
Denzel Mims from Baylor across from Adam
Thielen you know I like this pic a lot
Mims is such a high upside guy with his
the height weight speed profile that you
get I think he's a tough player one that
also wouldn't shock me here's Jalen
rhaegar I know that we as hosts are not
super high on him but I would not I
would not be surprised if the Vikings
draft him you still think there's
first-round buzz around rhaegar for a
couple teams I think there might a mean
it only takes one team and I do think
the Vikings have to go with a receiver
here after getting rid of a very good
one who wasn't happy but maybe corners
in play but I would rather take the the
big receiver in Mimms over a guy like
Gladney who might be there at 25 but I'm
not gonna let the Patriots take a
receiver or anybody in front of me I
like Mims I think that he can fit in
this offense and play across from
Thielen well sit tight because the
Vikings got another pick and corner
might be on the board 23 England
Patriots this is the third shock of the
giraffe guys I have New England having a
full-on quarterback competition because
they are taking Jalen Hertz at 23 Melo
how you feeling I don't want to talk
here I just don't think it's gonna
happen in the first round I do think the
Patriots like Jared Stidham and not
because he was my number one quarterback
because of the moves they've made around
him I think if they didn't like him they
would go target a guy like Jacoby
percent and try to bring him back and
they haven't or at least it doesn't seem
like they have it so I don't think
they're gonna go quarterback in the
first round I could see them do anything
like legitimately anything at this point
I have always leaned toward defense with
their MOX just that but that's just like
an instinct of Belichick trying to get
back to the roots of a strong defense
anything could happen here and it would
not I think Belichick is also too proud
to take a quarterback like this in the
first round because then it might send a
signal like oh I really miss Tom Brady
and I wish I had you back I think bill
will just be like [ __ ] it I don't care
we're not taking a quarterback we don't
need one I can win without a quarterback
and I also think that with
Hertz the Patriots really valued
decision-making and I think Hertz is a
question mark with it's a
decision-making I know he did great on
the board work at the combine and
everything but still you see some throws
I just don't know if he's a Patriots
type quarterback 24 the Saints they
bring back Jim Norris Jenkins they've
Marshawn Latimore but they are gonna get
themselves a slot corner here or a guy
that could play the slot right away and
that is Jeff Gladney at 24 from the
Saints I like this we don't talk enough
about how corner or excuse me how
secondary is I think a quiet need for
the Saints and their fans get so pissed
at me when I talk about this but if you
look at the reasons they've lost in the
playoffs it's not drew Brees
it's not Michael Thomas it's that
secondary so I would throw as many
swings the bad as I could at fixing that
group yeah I mean right here where
you're drafting you might as well you
know I mean you're probably getting a
starter but not like a superstar starter
so go add to your depth here I mean I
like Jenkins I really like Marshawn
Lattimore but you need a lot of corners
to be successful in the NFL and I think
gladden is physical enough that he can
come in and start a nickel immediately
and work his way into playing an outside
corner role for the Saints 25 the
Vikings are back on the clock again they
got Mims at 22nd overall now they're
gonna go to the corner board guys cuz
they are taking Christian Fulton here at
the end of round one such a good fit
schematically again like we talked about
the top of show if he's healthy the
value here is really really good it's
just a matter of do you feel like he's
over the ankle yeah you have to love the
the personality the dog in Christian
Fulton he's gonna match what Mike Zimmer
wants from his defenders and that
secondary needed a little bit of a
makeover I think they had to get rid of
some personalities Fulton is the kind of
guy you want to build a locker room
around and I think they like those big
physical corners and they definitely
need one here so I like this move I'm
starting to get very nervous though
Connor because you're having some
corners coming off the board my team
sitting at 32 and really needs well I
don't know they're gonna make it yeah
it's gonna be a close call here for your
Kansas City Chiefs but alright going
back on the clock here after the Vikings
load up 26 the Dolphins have been doing
some
themselves maybe not the best draft
they've had but a very realistic one
this is my favorite pic I did for them
26 Miami takes Cesar Ruiz mmm I like
that it is a I think an underrated area
of need as that interior offensive line
for them and with Ruiz to play Center or
either guard spot and be a very very
high caliber player yeah and I think he
probably goes a lot higher than some
people think I think that right here
with this pick might actually be on the
low end for him at 26 overall I think
he's a day one starter and I mean you
watch him move that sinner it reminds me
a lot of Garrett Bradbury who we saw go
pretty early in the first round I like
what he's gonna do with the Dolphins you
have to be able to protect the
quarterback that you got and even though
you have a left tackle you still need
that interior protection 27 the Seahawks
Jadeveon Clowney still unsigned they're
gonna go with a raw but super athletic
edge rusher here guys and ye tore gross
mottos I was wondering a while back
where you were gonna have him this is
just a really good pick if he's on the
board definitely the type of player they
need with clowny not signed at this
point even if clowny assigned might be
the type of player they need opposite in
because LJ Collier last year's first
rounder didn't do much man the Seahawks
have very little luck with late first
rounders when you look at who they've
drafted first round it's not good it's
they're so good after the first round
terrible in the first though yeah and I
do think to edge rusher is a big need
for them even if they do recycle Ani I'm
not sure what you're getting back
production-wise for him so I think that
even pairing him with a gross Matos or
replacing him with is a good call for
the Seahawks 28 the Ravens tell me if
you've heard this pic before guys
Kenneth Murray for the middle of that
Baltimore defense some guys are just
made to be Baltimore Ravens and Kenneth
Murray as well I'm captain at Oklahoma
incredible production tough against the
run but has that flow and juice to get
outside that the tackle box would make
place if Kenneth Murray's to pick here
is Australia yeah they've had some
success with some Oklahoma guys as well
Mark Andrews Orlando Brown Oklahoma
roots run deep there I'm gonna be pissed
I'll tell you guys that right now
because the Ravens are building
something pretty damn special there and
Kenneth Murray might be the only
linebacker
in these top three guys that can
actually come and play middle linebacker
immediately I think Queen might have to
play some off ball outside linebacker
I don't think Isaiah Simmons is a middle
linebacker but Kenneth Murray the best
true middle linebacker in this class
Falls to a team whose only need is that
middle linebacker like that's it that
everything else they have and it's gonna
make it very difficult to beat them in
the AFC which really sucks 29 Tennessee
Titans and named listeners of the show
are gonna get very familiar with this
week as we get to talk to him jaylen
Johnson comes off the board to add to
the Titans secondary yeah and talking to
people with the Titans they feel like
they could go a couple directions here
corner offensive tackle maybe even if
there's like a home run hitter with the
wide receiver position could be a spot
here but I think jaylen Johnson is a
great fit Mike variables gonna love the
student the only question and we're
gonna talk to jaylen for the winds-day
morning show where's he at with that
torn labrum that he waited to have
repaired until after the combine I mean
there are a lot of question marks Ryan I
didn't know if he's had it done because
that does that count it's an elective
surgery of so maybe all over the place
wasn't able to have it so we'll find out
Wednesday morning but I do like to fit
here yeah and a guy that will come in
and play nickel with a Dori Jackson and
Malcom Butler already there but again I
think a guy that can develop and
probably replace the Dori Jackson pretty
soon I just I haven't been real happy
with what he's able to do the shoulder
injury is he gonna be able to press I
don't know will he be able to run yeah
he's fine there and I think feet are the
most important thing for our corner and
hips and he's got both of them 30 the
Green Bay Packers a friendly reminder
this is not what I would do this is what
I think will happen Green Bay takes a
tackle prospect here guys in Austin
Jackson I don't hate it I think Green
Bay could go so many directions all of
them our future needs you know like if
Jordan love we're here I could see that
I think they've addressed a lot of their
needs through free agency there's not if
there's not a receiver that you value
here then keeping Aaron Rodgers
protected as he said recently he thinks
he could play till he's 40 you might go
that Tom Brady route so I do believe
Austin Jackson goes first round and I
know I'm I do this a lot it's like I
could see this happening and I think
this guy goes first round so
put these two together and I think that
the tackle position is such a bigger
need than Packers fans want to believe
they want to believe they still have the
best left tackle in all of football but
bakhtiari he's getting old he can chug
some beer but he did not look like the
same tackle last year that he has so I
think that this isn't a need going into
the 2020 season I think it's gonna be a
huge need in the 2021 season if you
don't address it now so if you're
sitting there you can take a tackle and
developing which is really important
with the way colleges play their offense
now especially you got like Jackson
who's coming from that you know spread
out wide offense it's not gonna be the
same as what he's gonna see in Green Bay
so taking stash him for a year making
your swing tackle your third tackle
maybe play him some guard and develop
him to be that replacement at left
tackle man he might have to replace Rick
Wagner if he if I know that's what I
when Ricky was healthy he was good but I
just don't know yeah tackle is gonna be
a need for the Green Bay Packers yeah
absolutely
palette that was my thought with that
pick the pick we've all been waiting all
right 31 the Niners they got CD lamb at
13 overall so what do you do at a team
it almost has everything guys you give
them a player that can do a little bit
of everything
Jeremy chin comes off the board to the
49ers I like it I thought you're gonna
say Xavier McKinney
I'll take Jeremy chin here that
athleticism as a matchup player if you
got a stop
you know the Tyler Higbee's for the Rams
okay he's got you if you want to stop
the run against the Seahawks he's got
you and just adding more Super Bowl
right yeah well no one can do that
just that speed at the second level with
Fred Warner Quan Alexander and now
Jeremy chin like that those are probably
your base starting linebackers within
chin doesn't ever leave the field you go
nickel do complain a slot he could play
everywhere I don't think you'd play
single high he could play everywhere
else so I hate to make such a cliche
comparison but this is some kam
chancellor for this defense I think
you've said everything there is to say
about Jeremy chin let's flashback like
six months and I tell you Jeremy Chin's
the first safety off the board you tell
me I'm smoking too much weed but I
thought I was six months ago well six
months six months ago we probably would
still say Delta it's gonna be first nine
months ago I would have said whoo
you said Jeremy chin yeah but I like
that pic I do think he fits like
everything that said yeah and once again
guys here at thirty-one for the Niner is
32 for the Chiefs I really would have
liked anterior offensive line but I'm
not taking Lloyd Cushing Barry here I'm
not taking you know any of the guards
Ruiz is gone so you're looking for
talent in the secondary the Niners get
that with chin 32 the Chiefs a guy that
I think fits their scheme very well AJ
Tyrell comes off the board is the last
pick in the first round
yeah you have to go corner like you
almost have to if you're the Kansas City
Chiefs so many needs on this defense I'm
glad you didn't go running back but I
was kind of getting into Sunday well I
think I'm trying to talk myself into my
fate you are running back I I think they
I think they will and that's what scares
me
I mellow and I talked about this on the
weekend that we almost feel like Veatch
like they're doing all this like run it
back they're bringing back to bring it
back all the receivers you know Sammy
Watkins restructures that they're almost
just gonna come into it and say no one
has time to prepare for us we were the
best team in football last year let's
just add like add someone who's ready to
play right now which running backs an
easy transition and then try to stop us
yeah I think he's just such a perfect
fit for that offense and what they want
to do with the receiver out of the
backfield Damian Williams I mean you
don't have to tell me he was good last
year I know this but I do think that the
Chiefs could look at this and say okay
we can get a guy who can be day one
corner three for us or get a Pro Bowl
running back and that's why I do that
Chiefs probably take a running back if
this is the way the board Falls
I mean AJ Terrell use what the fifth or
sixth corner here taken or you can have
the best running back and I slipped a
coin between him and Diggs yeah it's not
yeah not bad there because I do think
they're very very close on my board as
well I I really do feel like and I
people have tried to tell me this about
Andy Reid and Bret Beach they will not
let mahomes not have all the weapons he
needs like that is their priority it's
like we're gonna check that box yeah I
mean but they could still add more but
you're also looking at this
chart you're seeing of Ward and fitting
are your corners yeah you need somebody
else to come in there and do it because
the the guy they signed at corner
Antonio Hamilton I don't know who he is
and that can't be corner 3 when you're
trying to win another Super Bowl yeah
it's gonna be so much fun all right who
goes tomorrow me are you it doesn't
matter to me all right I'll go tomorrow
you've always been more of a stick to
football Friday guy so we'll let you go
Friday morning so tune in Wednesday
morning get my mock draft and get to
hear mellow and Connor rip mine apart
and we'll find a way to post Connor so
you guys could see the pics I know times
it's hard to keep up with an audio
version so look for that on the
Twitter's as well from O'Connor it's
Matt we'll talk to you all real soon